you know it's an amazing road you've
taken to acting I like your road to
acting because it looked like for a
while you weren't even going to be an
actor so here you are where'd you grow
up
Indiana okay you used to act in what
like elementary school right high school
high school yeah you did the high school
play
and you thought well I'll go to Julliard
and I'll become an actor right but you
got rejected right did you audition for
Juilliard yeah you did and they didn't
like your audition no it was not good
and so you said you something that's it
I'm not I'm not gonna be an actor I
can't get into Juilliard and that's it
it's over right that's it yeah and your
mom and stepdad you know you're in their
house and they say hey you graduated
high school you got to go do something
so they they gave you tough love right
yeah they said hey [ __ ] you go live in
the back and get a job right yeah they
were right to do that weren't they or
did it seem harsh to you no they were
right they always kind of told me that
was a plan soon as you turned 18 you're
gonna be paying rent here right yeah
we're gonna put you in the back of the
house you have to buy your own fridge
vacuum are you any good at that
no I was bad how much money did you make
so in here Oh zero
it's a commission job you never got
lucky no no no then also I didn't have
the balls to do that for a while like so
I would call my people at my parents
Church and they told you to [ __ ] off No
Wow in a way it's good acting training
you have to learn you have to put on a
face affiliation yes you do did you put
on his suit to sell the vacuum oh no no
I think I just wore like my dress
casuals yeah good look if you wanna sell
that and can you even meet women at that
point because are you dating or you
where you at with that yeah I had like a
girlfriend who were very why put that in
air quotes
we're very you know we're serious and
we're gonna get married right and she's
saying herself maybe I got to rethink
this guy because he's cute Jesus Christ
the guy kids so Levac you did she start
to say to you look I think you need to
make a little money before we get
married
yeah well I mean we're not together so
yeah did you have it when you were
selling vacuums did you have a port dirt
on the floor and you did oh my god I
figured that too that an instant sale no
we do you have to do those thing where
this is these ports are connected the
same things that NASA is using in space
it's the power that connects these two
I'm not very good at it no II don't you
terrible I would not buy a vacuum front
so then somebody says to you I think it
maybe was your stepdad
yeah he said why don't you go join the
[ __ ] Marines and become a man
Yeah right yeah I wasn't doing anything
we got a brochure in the mail and he's
like once you do that that's it steady
it seems like a very reasonable you know
it's a steady income there's always
they're always hiring you know right
vacuum right right
so 9/11 happens and you say to yourself
hey man you know what joining the
Marines seems like a good thing to do
I'll go over and kick some [ __ ] ass
over there right how hardcore is the
training it's pretty intensive the
Marine Corps is three months long the
basic training then you go to two months
after that Avesta why school of school
of infantry because I wanted to be in
the infantry and you would usually be
one of those guys that hits the ground
exactly why we're digging it yeah yeah
and you didn't sit the whole time ago
[ __ ] I wish I could just be an actor I
wish I could mean act you were like
full-on hardcore military yeah I love
being in the Marine Corps what's scarier
to you warfare or acting I mean those
are two warfare what I never got a
chance to go over and do that poor you
so you train and train you get your body
into physical shape you learn to be a
couple do they teach you weaponry oh of
course yeah yeah what he's firing off
well I was a mortarman but they trained
as a rifleman so are you a good shot
yeah yeah yeah qualified [ __ ] no not
that he can talk about wait a second you
didn't get to go over cuz she went
mountain biking and broke you back
that's different
would you like weight if so they kick
you out of the military because you
broke your sternum
yeah they draw me to a different unit
all my guys we're gonna go over and so
wait Afghanistan
yeah they did a West back so Afghanistan
in Iraq and and you were ready to go I
was yeah very ready to go were you
brokenhearted very much so yeah Wow even
now looking back on
I wish I could have gone I talk to them
all now and they have like are they like
what kind of [ __ ] are you acting yeah
that's a [ __ ] mode right yeah so you
get out of the military and you say hey
I'll go to Indiana University right you
know I'll go study acting there since I
can't get into Juilliard but then your
audition for Juilliard and you get in
there yeah yeah I got in yeah do you
think if you hadn't broken your sternum
you might have stayed in the military
and never gone took that new audition
with Juilliard and get back into act
yeah maybe yeah I was very interested in
making it a career